what's up everyone
lunch money time bang bang well while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
is trying to get our lunch money right
I'm here with the sale or herself plain
Tamara Nova stripe serger that's a train
that's not a ship what does the ship do
okay
don't forget lunch money is sponsored by
block buy right now they have a special
running this is a no-brainer special
block live.com slash lunch money if you
go there you open an account and you
deposit any amount of money they will
give you a double interest bonus so
normally you can earn up to eight point
six percent a py and an interest-bearing
account if you do this and fund the
account before July 18th they are going
to give you a double bonus in August I
mean that you will get double the
interest all you have to use is the
promo code two x the number two the
letter x go do it
no-brainer you get double the interest
in the month of August block five calm
slash lunch money or click on the link
in the description what's up hey hey so
you know how Amazon started it was on
crime fifteen years ago
has it been 15 years apparently so
alright yes I'm a prime member are you
I'm not you're one with me alright
Walmart fifteen years later is like oh
wait maybe we should do that so Walmart
is planning to launch something a new
subscription service later this month
called Walmart Plus that will cost
ninety eight dollars a year and it'll
include perks like same-day delivery of
groceries and general merchandise
discount on fuel at Walmart gas stations
in early access to product deals
how much is Amazon Prime if this started
out at 99 but I think it might be higher
now some people yeah but 98 is
right there uh do we know how many
Amazon Prime members there are in the
world I don't know can you google that
real quick the thing that's interesting
is I love these businesses for a couple
of reasons so Prime Costco is actually
very similar and then if you look at
what Amazon is doing and so Costco I've
talked to us before about Costco's yep
margin well here's why because what they
basically do is everyone pays $60 a year
annual membership and they find all of
these things and they sell them
basically at cost in Costco and if you
take the number of members times sixty
dollars for Costco that's basically
their profit margin all of the profit
comes from the subscription fee yeah and
everything else that cost how many
members 112 million Amazon Prime members
so to give you a sense that means that
they are making what is that
ten billion dollars right now right a
hundred yeah ten billion dollars they're
making if Prime is just a hundred bucks
a year yeah ten billion dollar
subscription business ain't bad that
ain't bad in the profiles only 50 so do
we think that Walmart is doing this in
response to a I mean I think it's about
time they kind of have no choice right
but you know it was interesting like I
was talking my mom about this if you buy
the same product at Walmart they still
ship it's like same day like you can
still get what's guaranteed now I think
it salty right yeah I guess so but I
thought that was a lot of people didn't
know that uh but yeah in kovat panic
buying has helped to boost Walmart sales
to record highs earlier this year so
Walmart's not doing bad you know who is
doing bad who Brooks Brothers Brooks
Brothers so Brooks Brothers is was
founded in 1818 and I think by the
Brooks Brothers what Oh probably alright
it's a it's a fine gentleman retailer
they also sell some stuff for a woman
but I'm not sure if filed for bankruptcy
on Wednesday you do not
Brooks Brothers nah I ain't a Brooks
brother type dude don't wear the same in
colored shorts or have my collar popped
Oh God
that's what the Brooks Brothers crowd
does Brooks Brothers has boasts of
having dressed 40 US president and
countless investment bankers you also
know who else has dressed a lot of
presidents Walmart Wrangler jeans I bet
you Wrangler jeans has because every
president where's the old dad jeans so
well so this is this is kind of sad it's
one of the country's oldest and most
prestigious retailers and now it's
filing for bankruptcy yeah but remember
it's not going away it's just gonna go
through a capital restructuring it'll
still be here and look at the end of the
day like this is kind of everything's
already happening right in the sense of
the virus just accelerated trends like
physical retail is becoming less popular
if I can buy the same stuff the same
stuff elsewhere why wouldn't I so the
salmon shorts aren't going away as what
you're trying to say one I don't think
those are going away but to also on top
of that is like there's just new brands
that pop up like Peter Millar is a great
example there's a guy I know who who
used to work there and it's like
compound golf type fashion whatever but
like that brand all the sudden comes on
the scene and people like the new fresh
more modern version of what first
brother has and also like the other
piece of this too is but you a lot of
the customer base for Brooks Brothers is
an older population and you just buy
less clothes as you get a little you
don't need new clothes to go to work
every day right if you're retired and
things like that so I don't know I think
Brooks Brothers there's some young 25
year old men with popped collars out
there do you want to know a fun fact
what it is owned by Claudio Del Vecchio
Vecchia whatever who's the son of the
Italian I wear giant looks so exotic
luxottica people don't know that I just
learned Mex led intern okay all right
what's going on with uber uber uber
either the tech press four years have
than asking over CEO and trying to
figure out when this company will turn a
profit now uber CEO says it will become
profitable next year thanks to the post
mates acquisition so it's very
interesting I think that uh the kind of
the uber eats post weights division is
doing better than the ride-hailing oh
yeah well there's a couple of pieces to
this that I think are very interesting
so one you had the legacy business that
was the core business that was really
the whole business when they launched he
reads it was like core business move
reads now you've got this going on at
some point I still think you reads only
makes up like twenty percent or 25
percent of revenue so it hasn't quite
kind of overtaking it the core business
but eventually it will and if you think
about the unit economics are better it's
easier right for them to operate and so
they're gonna make a big ploy yet or
they're gonna make a big push into it
they're the second largest food delivery
service in the United States
they're the first largest ride-sharing
service and so they're doing exactly
what you expect whether you're moving
humans or food it's all logistics who
would have thought when Hoover launched
that it was gonna have an uber each
division that's gonna do better than its
core business Travis kalanick
right because again it all comes down to
just being logistics and by the way uber
at some point we'll probably do packages
as well I think they've tested it before
packages just think about all I need to
do is I need to move something from
point A to point B that could be a human
that could be food that could be a
package that could be all kinds of stuff
and so that's really what they're in
there in the logistics business so this
makes sense darah
the CEO said we're in the unique
position of having the eats business to
significantly offset headwinds in our
rides business because I guess it
suffered during kovin but look at how
great it is to have multiple streams of
revenue eighty percent loss in the
ride-sharing business from what I
understand while the obviously eats
business or the food delivery businesses
have all exploded in popularity makes
sense ooh
tinder what's going on tinder let's say
excite about tinder
I might need to do some product tests
oh just kidding so tinder is testing its
video dating feature so now when you
match with a person it's gonna unlock
the video capability so you can both
meet via video so you can do just so I
understand this I could then do like a
video conference like a first date
virtually I think so yeah almost like
space time why don't you just face time
because you don't want something on your
phone
oh yeah that's right right see that big
privacy guy now like I think about it if
you're a girl and you match with
somebody and you then give them your
cell phone number then they're like
calling you they're doing all kinds of
weird you can just unmatch them right
yeah so like I mean this makes a lot of
sense especially when it comes to
protecting people's privacy protecting
their information all that kind of stuff
and the other piece too is my guess is
that like this was accelerated if I were
already working on it but it was
accelerated by the pandemic but it just
goes back to this idea of like are you
is everything just gonna be virtual but
ready player one is a great example yeah
were you just I'm gonna look into my
portal here into my virtual world and
when I do that now all of a sudden I'm
gonna meet somebody there I'm gonna hang
out with them there well I think with
kuben because you're probably not going
on real life face to face dates this is
the best first option before you know
you put yourself at risk and go on a
date with somebody why are you putting
yourself at risk just wear a mask okay
by the way I still think it's funny that
wasn't the CDC somebody put a look she's
trying they're the CDC I think was them
gave guidance for if you're gonna have
sex to wear a mask
I'm just saying okay um well so this is
interesting
tinder tinder is trying to like prompt
people to agree on some ground rules
from its Community Guidelines keep it PG
no nudity or sexual content I have a
feeling they're not gonna be able to
hold
this well and girls already suffer from
gross dude sending them pictures they
don't want that I don't know what this
video I feel like you putting yourself
at some risk of seeing some stuff you
don't want to see I'm willing to bet
that women provide more nude nudity or
non PG content than men no yes not
unwanted oh uh 'none that is a different
thing but I'm just saying the look at
the end of the day this is a big
technical challenge right like but if
you try to use computer vision or any
sort of the court official intelligence
object detection like there's all kinds
of things that you can do a lot of
platforms have spent a lot of time
building this type of stuff so like
Facebook these people have a photo gets
uploaded they try to be able to tell it
what's in the photo all that kind of
stuff so they can scale the the kind of
community governance it's gonna be
really hard to do on live video because
there's probably no there's probably
trying to be have as little delay as
possible do we think that tinder is
saving this data and this video content
I mean I have no clue but again you know
we saw what tik toks doing so I wouldn't
mess around that
all right what's gone with Kanye okay
Kanye Kanye is a genius Kanye freaking
loves forms and he did an exclusive
interview with them and he disclosed
that he is running for president 2020
under a new banner the birthday party
with guidance from Elon Musk in an
obscure vice presidential candidate he's
already chosen who do we think it is Oh
Kim no you don't think so no I bet I
mean it would be cool if he did that
they wouldn't win but it'd be highly no
yeah my guess is that it is Jenner no my
guess is that it is somebody in the
business world that people really
respect and will be surprised but
impress Charlie Munger oh yeah I mean
look I don't believe him that he's
actually running to win because he
hasn't even filed the paperwork yet see
get you can't even get on the ballot if
you didn't follow paperwork but can't he
do that as a write-in candidate he could
try as a write-in candidate but like
that's never happened and is very
unlikely to happen yeah well here's my
favorite part of this profile they asked
him why the birthday party platform in
this was his response because when we
win is everybody's birthday ain't that
the truth by the way Polina left out a
detail that I just read what he already
announced who his running mate it was
who's Michelle tin ball an obscure
preacher from Wyoming oh he loves the
preachers so he has a preacher that is
not a business person whatever Michelle
didn't even know that she was getting
announced here and unveiled yeah so
Michelle tin ball is the proposed
president for running mate and I think
that they call her let's see here real
quick yeah look Oh life coaches bibble
biblical life coach
remember Kanye has a church aid to be
honest has got popping music it's the
best musical performance in a church in
America right all right what's next so
Kat Cole bang bang so a friend over here
interviewed Kat Cole video is out today
I got I had the pleasure of listening to
it live she is an absolute savage
actually truth she was the president and
CEO of focus brands a company doing
nearly 5 billion in annual revenue and
they she's a former president of focus
brands subsidiary Cinnabon and prior
test she was an executive vice president
of Hooters so Kat Cole started out at 17
years old as a waitress at Hooters rose
in the company over about 15 years to
become the executive vice president she
went around she was opening all of these
stores for Hooters all around the world
in Australia and South America etc and
her young 20s she eventually early 20s
she eventually was recruited to become
the president of Cinnabon and she led
the turnaround of Cinnabon during the
financial crisis
and then Cinnabon is owned by focused
brands which is kind of a holding
company a parent company they also own
Auntie Anne's most Southwest Grill Jamba
Juice a bunch of brands that you would
know and so she runs the whole thing's
five plus billion dollar about five
billion dollars in revenue and so I
highly suggest going and listening to
this interview for two reasons one it is
by far the most insight per minute that
we've ever had on the podcast like she
she just has been doing this for a very
long time and is able to articulate
business lessons that you could go pay
for an MBA and you'll never get like she
has specific anecdotes and examples what
was your favorite thing she said my
favorite thing is that she said most
people would be better off if they did
one thing in their professional careers
which is when you receive criticism
immediately default to the idea that
it's true and then operate from that
perspective most people when they get
criticism they immediately they pull
back or they fight it they yeah they
argue there they get defensive they
don't want to believe it but you said if
you simply get criticism and you just
say that's probably true how do I fix it
let me go learn more right and kind of
attack it that way you'll be way way
better off you said that all is kind of
one piece it's just the amount of
business knowledge and this episode is
incredible the second thing that I will
say though is you get it here just
really cool stories around what they've
done to combat a lot of trends so
they've got stores and malls a lot of
people think mall traffic is going down
so what are they gonna do food
deliveries become this hot thing right
the pandemic obviously shut down a bunch
of the diet fads yeah yeah people don't
want to eat
Cinnabons every day right so just we go
through kind of all of the things that
they've had to deal with and she's able
to articulate like this was the problem
here are our options we chose to move
before with this option and here's how
it played out it said these people
really enjoy um can I tell you my
favorite part of it sure I so she
explained that she was like six or nine
months into the job and the founders son
she made a decision and the founders son
emailed her from cinema from Cinnabon
and he's normally a very mild manner
man she said but she received an email
from him that said all caps
WTF in a million exclamation points and
she was like oh no so anybody who
receives that email is bound to like
freeze or freak out or you know try to
respond it's a weird way she said I did
the only thing that you have to do to
earn their respect which is pick up the
phone and I can give you immediately and
call him and try to understand the
situation and I think that's so true
because so many times we let things
linger and you let things fester or we
respond back with some
passive-aggressive email that's just no
help so I think that like to remedy any
situation you just directly pick up the
phone or go in person if you can and get
to the bottom of it yeah basically the
more time you let elapsed during an
issue the worse it gets if you can very
quickly just say oh wait there's an
issue let me attack that issue in terms
of let me work to solve it and
immediately talk to somebody ends up
being pretty effective and you know what
I love I love that she's like me yes I
love that she's like honest about she's
like I literally cried my eyes out every
day for two weeks and all this stuff and
like you don't actually ever cure
business people talk about that stuff
but because of those experiences she's
learned to become so confident in all of
her decisions and I think that's what
makes a really great business leader
yeah it's super impressive go watch it
any last parting words for the people um
be kind to your friends this weekend is
safe Wednesday there's one thing okay so
we choked oh my god I thought we got
away with her if you have 45 seconds
okay what did the doggy got away with it
what did the duck say when he bought
lipstick what did the duck say when he
bought here she
it was quack 'fl what does that mean oh
um put it on my bill see it's pretty
good it's a pretty good
I might start reading your jokes that's
like a 5.4 what yeah five points in 8.9
know where your tough graders Ronnie I
didn't even laugh I just kind of thought
okay what was a nine the one that you
laughed that's it for lunch money today
guys we'll talk to you tomorrow while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get a lunch money right
get money get paid choo-choo bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by block five so go check them out
there's a link in the description that
you can click on I'm an investor a user
and a huge fan what you're a bigger fan
of block fire than you are of me block
wise my second favorite thing in the
world behind polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy plan in the
comment and we'll see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends